joining us right now to talk some
football and the latest in what is going
on in the National Football League that
does have a draft three weeks from last
night going down three weeks from today
will be rounds two and three of the NFL
Draft
mm QB senior reporter good friend Albert
prior back on the show how are you
Albert yeah we are I hope everybody like
you and your family I know you got young
kids and I know you know you've got an
extended family I hope everybody is
healthy and safe wherever they are to
offer yeah I appreciate that you know my
wife's a nurse so it's been it's been an
interesting comment elders Hospital so a
little bit different position but I
gotta tell ya I what some of the stories
she comes home what they're amazing so I
you know I start with that like just
anybody you know come to the contact
with a doctor or nurse they know over
the next few weeks be sure to thank them
for their no doubt about Albert you know
I feel like you know we we talk about
them in a manner in which you know we
should always because without health
there's really nothing we can do um we
talk about them in many ways that we
talk about members of the military
thanking them for their service is
basically what we're doing right now
because this is a war I mean that's a
frontline that they're on right now to
battle this virus to get everybody
healthy and back to normal so I think
that's a place yeah you know you think
about it yeah you know and there's some
of our best people I mean I I've always
said this hey but the people I meet who
are in that field and I got some of my
family I can mention my wife my I've got
an uncle who's a surgeon and you know I
think for a lot of them it's like the
military too and that it's a calling for
them you know and I know that's
certainly the case my wife and I just
you know I think for a lot of them they
don't need to be thanked because they
feel like you know in a lot of ways it's
their purpose is why they're here you
know but I do know you know after you
know hearings how stressful it is going
in there our day to day basis now you
know does help you know hear from other
people so yeah they're very much you
know I again I think there's some of our
best people you know our doctors and
nurses
and it can't it can't hurt anything - it
doesn't cost anybody anything so glad to
those people you know like it's well
said that it's you know it's similar to
you know a soul through being the front
line to battle
well Albert well said let's get because
of their hard work and no we still have
the ability to talk about sports and
talk about pop culture and entertainment
and provide a respite so top story of
the day and the NFL is without a doubt
Ryan pace and Matt Negi coming out today
GM and coach of the Bears saying what we
all assumed that Nick Foles is coming to
compete it's an open competition at the
quarterback spot in Chicago how in the
world is that going to play out
Albert it's gonna be interesting too
because they're not gonna have the
spring in all likelihood to go through
it you know and so it's going to be I
think ascetically a little bit of a fire
drill want to get to the summer and I
think at the same time I think part of
the reason why the Bears pursued the way
they did I know part of the reason they
pursued the way they did the quarterback
position was because they knew they were
gonna have to a continue to get mr.
Bisky reps if they wanted to give any
chance at all and be find a way to bring
in somebody new who would be able to get
it up to speed quickly and that's why
the two guys they targeted and when they
were looking at different trade options
were Andy Dalton the Nick Foles because
both those guys had background in the
system and so the fact that Foles was
with you know John deep Aleppo in
Philadelphia the fact that he was with
Matt maggie and kansas city's huge have
to get him up to speed on quite as much
as you wanted normal do player and I
think it's also at the same time kind of
an acknowledgment of where they're at I
mean they're they've got an awful lot of
players that are right in the prime of
their careers you know guys like Coolio
Mac and Eddie Jackson and you know and
Foley's going on down the line there are
a lot of guys they're sort of square in
the prime of their careers this window
isn't going to last forever and so I
think they knew they need a better
product production out of that position
based on whether staff situation is you
know they're probably going to have to
make you know some hard decisions over
the next couple of
some guys and so you know you you just
let the two guys compete you see what
you can do and try to get the most out
of this sort of group of Chicago Bears
and that's you know that's that's going
to be where they're at going into camp
is make a decision as quickly as you can
so then you can kind of give the team
the word on who the quarterback is going
to be then you can build around that guy
but you know certainly a big part of
this without question is the fallout or
the decision to take mr. Bisky over to
show and watch you want to talk about
you know an admission of where you are
when you use that phrase a moment ago I
thought you were gonna you were
referring to the second overall pick of
the draft now four drafts ago or
soon-to-be four drafts ago taken over
the reigning MVP of the Super Bowl and
an MVP candidate year in and year out a
very special player in deshaun Watson
and admitting that you need to bring in
competition for him and and there won't
be any competition as you point out in
the spring in which to make a decision
whether you pick up a fifth year option
right I mean how is that all going to
work right Albert I don't know I don't
know they can't pick up the fifth year
option that's tough because you know I
am look like this year is only enjoyed
guaranteed the difference you know the
different aspects that a CBA don't kick
in till next year so it will only be
injured guaranteed if they pick up the
mitts
mr. risky secure option but it's
expensive and if he gets hurt then
you're on the hook for it and so here's
a cookie about that is you know if you
do decide okay we're going to pick up
the 50 or option on him well then if he
doesn't win the job you're in the
situation the Redskins were in however
many years ago Robert Griffin and you
remember that rich he was a healthy
scratch every week and they had to carry
three quarterbacks on the roster Colt
McCoy was there too as a result of that
which means you lost one player off the
team and part of that for the Redskins
was well we want to show confidence that
you know we still believe in in Robert
Griffin so then you decide you're not
going to pick up the 50 rod well then
you know now what's necessary said it's
a bit risky you didn't pick up the
option your product Nick Foles and so
how's that gonna affect him but it's a
tricky situation and again
I mean it I think Ryan Agee has done a
good job of building that team up over
the over the last couple of years but my
god you know is if you look at the if
you look at the fallout from that one
decision single decision to go with mr.
biskay and trade up for mr. burski when
deshaun Watson and Patrick Mahone are
seeing right there forum for them you
know it's right there for ya I mean just
just a major major you know major major
I could call what it is
screw up there to go in one direction
not one of two others Albert Brewer from
Sports Illustrated mm QB senior reporter
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
cam and Jameis I think that they're
gonna have to wait to the draft to see
how chips fall before they go ahead and
get a gig what do you think what's the
market like yeah well I mean I did one
job that still seems to be open as the
Chargers and I know the Chargers are
doing all their homework on the guys are
gonna be available and so part of this
could come down to who falls to them
with a sixth pick or if they're willing
to trade up and I mean look like you
know having Tyrod Taylor there if you're
gonna draft a guy that high you sort of
have a formal quarterback room so they
weren't able to get somebody they like
you know you know with the six overall
taker through a trade up and that will
be an opening for one of those two guys
I think the biggest issue for both them
though is the fact that they can't go in
and sit in the team facility and get
checked out you know and and with Cam
afford is physical you know where's his
right shoulder at you know where's his
left foot at like how is he look
physically team is gonna want two teams
wanna have their doctors get a hands on
a guy like that so that's a serious
issue for him and then what Jameis I
think as much as anything it's going to
sit down and kind of talk to the guy at
there's five years in Tampa and see
where he's at mentally and so I think
we're both those guys didn't really been
hurt by the fact that they can't go into
these facilities and sit down and talk
to people and I think it's you know
right now it's sort of these both guys
kind of a precarious situation where I
cams got to prove after being the
centerpiece of everything in Carolina
being the centerpiece at Auburn be
the centerpiece at Junior College that
he can kind of you know exist is
somebody who might be a little bit less
than that and he's gotta prove he's
healthy and then Jameis you know I think
the best thing for him may be to go to a
place that's got a starter in place and
I'd establish starter in place where you
know it's a stable franchise he can
rehabilitate his stock maybe something
like what Teddy Bridgewater had to do
under different circumstances where he
went to New Holland it's got really good
coaching and a couple years later having
been there for two years really paid off
well there's two other spots to where
you look across the landscape and you
got two second-year players who are
seemingly the starting quarterbacks at
their current spots right now one with a
lot more experience than the other
you've got Gardner Minshew in
Jacksonville will they stick with him
and then there's Jerrod Stidham I know
they brought in Hoyer for the umpteenth
time in New England
I mean how will those quarterback rooms
be affected by the next few times do you
think well there's a very real kind of
like timeline you can look through that
sort of explain why New England they
think they've got a first-round talent
on their hands if you look at your
theorems Dacron he was the number one
high school quarterback in the country
coming out of high school right he goes
to Baylor starts as a true freshman
plays well and then of course the sexual
abuse scandal blows up so his coach gets
fired and he has to transfer he
transfers to Auburn where they're
running the offense that was built for
Cam Newton which isn't a great fit for
him so when the Patriots drafted him in
the fourth round last year they sort of
looked at the distressed asset you know
a guy who's got a hug got great talent
great kid checked off a lot of boxes but
didn't play that well ecology because he
was in a situation that didn't fit him
great which really wasn't his fault
if you look at the timeline of it and so
I think they do want to give him a shot
doesn't mean they're not going to draft
somebody but if you're looking at it
it's you know his situation where he's
at his price tag their cap situated up
and there's opportunity there for them
to sort of come out of 20/20 with real
clean financials of the court of
position after carrying a thirteen and a
half million dollar dead money hit on
Brady this year as for Jacksonville I
think that they do they are gonna give
themselves some insurance behind behind
Gardner Minshew I just wouldn't be
surprised if it's not in I would be so I
wouldn't be surprised that it's actually
Andy Dalton not cam or Jameis and the
reason why is because Jay Gruden's there
yep and big written work with Andy
Dalton his first three years in a week
there's a very close relationship there
and we know the kind of guy Andy Dalton
is that maybe personality wise he would
sit behind a young quarterback a little
bit better than the other two and so III
think you know you look at both those
situations it could be opportunity if
the bottom just falls out on either
camera Jameis and the price is so cheap
they have to look at it but I think in
both situations there's probably a
different path that those teams are
going last one for you Albert brear
three weeks from today we will be
through the first round of the NFL Draft
your best guess on the top three picks
and who chooses them three weeks from
today that we're talking about the top
three picks would be who and by whom
Albert okay I would tell you the Bengals
have done so much work on show thorough
and this includes I mean it goes back
they've used every resource and pulled
every lever and it's gonna I don't know
people know this but bilborough's ex
college roommate bro you know obviously
Zack Taylor has a relationship with Jill
burrows dad Jimmy burrow he's at one
time Jimmy burrow was at Ohio University
and Zach Hill was at the University of
Cincinnati each other out recruiting and
so the Bengals have just kind of like
moved every mountain it's no joke girl
as well as they possibly can I think
they're going to take him number one
overall which is the shot here and then
you know my guess is the Redskins kind
of do a walk-on kula they kick the tires
on a trade and then they wanted to take
a chase young second and then I think
the Lions are third set
I don't think the lines want to move
down too far
so they love for a Miami or a Los
Angeles but the Chargers come up and get
that pick because you know the top of
this draft there are going to be formaly
defensive players Jayceon come on
Jeff included another Derrick brown and
Isaiah symptoms or the other two so I
did the Lions would love to be in a
situation where they could trade down
and still not fall out a range to get
one of those guys so if they stick where
they are because they traded Darius
Slade I guess it'd be Jeff Okuda it's
not a home that that's not me being a
homer but that's the way I don't go but
I do think but I do think they're gonna
do everything they can to try to create
a market for that third overall pick
thanks for the call Albert best to your
wife best your family let's chat next
week week after to look for my call
we'll make this on the regular before
the draft that's for sure you got it
that's Albert prayer right here in the
Rich Eisen show